[Aplausos]
qué pasaría hacia el día de hoy te
quedará sin ingresos hoy fue el último
día te pidieron de tu trabajo tuviste un
accidente te complicas te no tienes
ingresos
cuántos meses sobreviviría
321 ninguna la quincena
no se preocupen hemos encontrado la
vacuna que cura la pobreza
pero antes de esto les quiero hablar un
poquito sobre mí a finales del 2008 yo
estaba completamente quebrado no me dio
en problema do no con un poco de
problema estaba más reventado que un
cuento en navidad
sé lo que es pasar un año sin pagar el
colegio de mis hijos sé lo que es que
las tarjetas de crédito me den los
buenos días las buenas tardes y las
buenas noches sé perfectamente lo que es
del carro parqueado con miedo que te lo
vayan a quitar
toda la angustia y todos los temas que
te pueden generar tener problemas
financieros
los he vivido como protagonista
principal
y es lo mejor que me ha pasado en la
vida
esto ha desatado la locura porque el día
de hoy yo me encuentro completamente
libre de deudas y si yo hubiera agarrado
todo lo que debía y hubiera aplicado el
mejor mes de mi vida no me alcanzaba dos
vidas para pagarlo no tengo saldo en las
tarjetas de crédito no tengo ninguna
préstamo personal no tengo extra
financiamientos no debemos nuestra casa
no debemos los gastos estamos pagando la
universidad de nuestros hijos por
adelantado y en realidad no es cuestión
de suerte no tiene que ver nada con qué
inteligente creas que sos o no no tenés
que ver nada con cuánto dinero ganas el
20% de conocimiento y 80% de
comportamiento la libertad financiera
verdaderamente es algo espectacular y
todo el mundo debería de entender debe
entender y debería de tener un plan para
lograr que puede ser un plan que en tu
vida
puedas tener para poder cumplir y hacer
tu sueño realidad
les voy a hablar un poquito de lo que
nosotros vemos en el día a día por eso
es que yo soy un poco radical con estas
cosas hicimos un estudio hace cuatro
años en el cual entrevistamos más o
menos a 250 ejecutivos voy a poner
personas con los mejores puestos de
trabajo que existían o que existe en el
salvador ahí habían abogados habían
doctores habían gerentes generales de
empresas habían directores ejecutivos de
empresas multinacionales gente con
licenciaturas con maestrías gente con
doctorados el mayor nivel de ingresos
después de que nos sentamos con todos
ellos sólo cuatro de los 250 tenían una
planificación financiera formal sólo
cuatro sabían cómo relacionarse con el
dinero correctamente
eso es el 1.6 por ciento de la población
en el segmento más educado del país
imagínense de ahí
cuando yo les pregunte a estas personas
en quien te lo enseño quién te enseñó
esto y ninguno me dijo que se lo había
enseñado en su casa a sus papás nadie me
dijo que se lo habían enseñado en el
colegio o en la universidad los cuatro
habían tenido la oportunidad de tomar un
curso de planificación financiera
y estas cuatro personas no sólo lo
habían tomado sino que aplicaban estos
conceptos sencillos en su día a día y no
tenían problemas estas personas tenían
un balance general sabían cuánto dinero
tenían y cuánto dinero debían y lo
medían todos los meses para ver si su
patrimonio crecía de un presupuesto
balanceado ya sabían cuáles gastos eran
mensuales y cuáles eran no mensuales
ahorraban para emergencias y cuidaban
dinero para su futuro esta gente estaban
protegidos ante las cosas que no podían
manejar tenían los seguros correctos y
tenían un protocolo de inversión pero lo
principal de todo es que no tenían
deudas de consumo son como yo tengo 10
años de ser rehabilitados no consumo no
tengo tarjetas de crédito
estas personas verdaderamente tenían
libertad financiera
ahora nosotros tenemos un programa a
donde a través de las empresas le
llevamos salud financiera a los
empleados y hemos tomado unas 25.000
encuestas han pasado todos ellos por un
seminario que quisiera tener cuatro
horas para contarles todo lo que hacemos
pero les tomamos una encuesta sobre su
situación financiera la muestra es tan
de que el resultado ya no cambia es el
mismo y yo lo puedo decir que aplica tal
vez a todos ustedes y se los traemos
aquí para que ustedes lo puedan ver uno
de cada diez salvadoreños económicamente
activos está solvente eso es el 10 por
ciento de nuestra población
de decir que todos los meses gastan
menos de lo que gana y todos los meses
está acumulando dinero y tiene un
patrimonio más grande
dos de cada diez personas o el 20 por
ciento de la población económicamente
activa
vive de cheque a cheque estos son los
que el viernes hablan a recursos humanos
y dicen van a depositar el viernes o
este lunes
hay algunos aquí
estas son personas que aunque parece que
están saliendo viven al límite y si uno
de los dos si en un lugar de doble
ingreso pierde el trabajo se metieron en
problemas si les chocaron el carro si
les se les enfermó un hijo y no tienen
el seguro correcto van endeudados
entonces están con la línea hasta la
nariz el verdadero problema empieza aquí
cuatro de cada diez salvadoreños van
camino a la quiebra y no se han dado
cuenta todavía
estas son personas que en el mes a mes
gastan siempre un poquito más de lo que
ganan
y la única manera que alguien te puede
que puede gastar más dinero del que tú
ganas sin ser mago es si alguien te lo
presta
y en las encuestas estamos hecho
nosotros hemos determinado que la
penetración de tarjetas de crédito es de
dos puntos una tarjeta de crédito por
persona económicamente activa es que son
unos animalitos espectaculares yo gasto
cien dólares y me cobran cinco él no se
multiplica mi dinero por 20
yo quiero 4
entonces qué es lo que sucede gano 500
gastó 600 y esos 100 tengo que pagar 5 y
parece que sostenible pero repito ese
proceso una y otra vez porque estas
personas no tienen un sistema para darse
cuenta si están gastando más de lo que
ganan o no
entonces esos cinco se hacen 10 20 40 80
200 y cuando estoy allí si me preocupo
empieza a palpitar el corazón
y voy a pedir ayuda y en el banco me
dicen no se preocupe lo vamos a ayudar
le vamos a bajar la tasa 3 qué buena
gente el banco y le vamos alargar el
plazo y ese pago de 300 se vuelve 71
dice soy un genio financiero
esto debería haber estudiado voy a
aplicar a un trabajo de finanzas y creo
que resuelto el problema ahora yo sé que
el problema entre comillas son las
tarjetas y entonces las castigo las meto
en una gaveta y les digo castigadas no
vuelven a salir y empiezo a hacer mi
vida sin hacer eso sin ocupar las tantas
pero como a los tres días pasó cerca de
la gaveta y oigo
pobre si están encerradas tres días en
lo oscuro
entonces la saco y big solo para
emergencias la voy a ocupar y me la meto
en la cartera y cuando estoy en la
cuarta cerveza ya no tengo castigo esta
es una emergencia y me quiero tomar otra
y vuelvo a caer en ese ciclo y nosotros
hemos visto zonas que se tardan hasta 10
años en llegar a donde está el otro 30%
de las personas que está quebrada
todo el mundo tiene un límite de
capacidad de endeudamiento
entonces ese 30% nosotros decimos que en
promedio en el salvador los presupuestos
se componen de 70 por ciento de
necesidades y 30% de deseos yo con el 70
por ciento de mi dinero me debería de
asegurar de comprar y de tener casa
alimentación medicinas transporte y
educación para mis hijos eso es lo que
se necesita para tener una vida digna
eso va antes que cualquier cosa eso
debería de ir primero con el otro 30% de
mi dinero yo me divierto con eso me
compré un uniforme soy el capitán del
equipo de la colonia y si soy mujer me
pinto el pelo de rojo de verde me leen
con 8 me lo planchó me compro los
zapatos que mueven el piso y todas esas
cosas pero cuando yo vengo cuando yo
vengo y las responsabilidades
financieras que yo tengo son iguales al
30 por ciento de mis ingresos
entonces yo ya no estoy viviendo solo
estoy sobreviviendo
trabajo para nada si fueran negocios no
doy utilidades
si es mayor a eso estoy quebrado porque
porque se está metiendo con mi dignidad
no tengo una vida digna ya no la puedo
generar y qué es lo que sucede nos
programan todo el tiempo para que
podamos generar todo vamos al colegio a
la universidad para tener el mejor
trabajo para tener el mejor ingreso para
poder cubrir mis necesidades y todo esté
enfocado en generar y si la vacuna que
cura la pobreza la fórmula fuera generar
entonces no tuviéramos a esos boxeadores
y jugadores portistas profesionales que
han ganado millones de dólares y al
final de su vida están haciendo un
partido benéfico para que puedan comer
para que tengan casa entonces generarnos
solución del problema
nosotros podemos empezar a generar
cuando tenemos 20 años más o menos y
como a los 65 se nos quitan las ganas
hay veces que antes
entonces tenemos 45 años para generar y
es importante pero no es lo más
importante
normalmente nosotros queremos también
aprender a administrar y yo debería de
empezar también desde los 20 años o
antes y llegar hasta el último día de mi
vida administrando qué es esto es
cumplir el principio básico de la
libertad financiera vivir por debajo de
mis posibilidades nos cuesta tanto
pero eso como eso no garantiza todavía
el problema lo que nos garantiza es que
tenemos que aprender a multiplicar el
dinero que salvamos en el mes a mes nos
debería de sobrar y lo deberíamos de
poner a trabajar para que se multiplique
solo para que eso cubre nuestros gastos
de vida cuando cuando el dinero que yo
tengo ahorrado e invertido me produce
suficiente para cubrir gastos de vida
entonces yo tengo libertad financiera y
esa es la fórmula que deberíamos de
tener generar más administrar más
multiplicar esto me da libertad
financiera y quiero que le pongan
atención porque esto es el mensaje más
importante yo entro al juego de la vida
con el mismo uniforme con el que yo
salgo ya saben cual uniforme va
toulon
1 / chulo ni sale chulo entonces no
debería de ser el objetivo de la vida
acumular dinero porque sabemos que al
final todos vamos a llegar con el mismo
marcador que es cero entonces el
objetivo de la vida no puede ser
acumular el objetivo de la vida debe ser
dejar una huella es hacer un impacto ese
debería de ser el objetivo entonces si
yo aplico bien la fórmula el recurso más
preciado que las personas tienen es el
tiempo y se nos va a la velocidad de un
día a la vez entonces si yo logro tener
libertad financiera lo que va a pasar es
que voy a tener la libertad de hacer lo
que me apasiona y voy a poder cambiar el
mundo y voy a poder dejar una huella si
el día de hoy yo les hiciera un cheque y
le dijera están garantizados de sus
ingresos por el resto de su vida a que
le dedicarán su tiempo
estuviéramos cambiando el mundo
estuviéramos curando enfermedades
estuviéramos ayudando al niño huérfano
estuviéramos haciendo las cosas que
aunque estuviéramos haciendo arte
estuviéramos haciendo teatro tuviéramos
tantos mensajes que sean para el alma
de eso se trata esta fórmula te va a
liberar para que vos puedas hacer ese
tema para que vos puedas cambiar eso
para que vos tengas la verdadera
libertad de poner los dones y talentos
que tú tienes al servicio de los demás
ese es el objetivo de la vida ese es
nuestro propósito
yo estoy dando una tierrita para que
rompan esa cadena porque yo sé que aquí
hay cosas espectaculares
les vamos a contar la historia del pedró
pescado igual pescador rápidamente
este es pedro pescado tiene 10.000
dólares ahorrados quiere una casa de 100
mil puede pagar 700 dólares al mes va
pide al banco 90 mil dólares de préstamo
el 8 y medio por 30% y tiene 600 37
dólares de cuota de intereses y 63 a
capital juan pescador que está vacunado
contra la pobreza también tiene 10 mil
puede pagar 700 pero decide comprarse
una casita en un en vez de la casota
sacó un préstamo de 55 mil al 8 y medio
por 30 años y le queda una cuota de 350
le estaba feliz porque creía que iba a
gastar más pero le dicen no
de la cuota principal 310 se van a
intereses y 390 se van a capital diez
años más tarde pedro pescado abonado
diez mil dólares a su deuda y sólo debe
80 mil
pescador ya pagó su casita vende su
casita compra su casa saca un préstamo
de 35 mil dólares le quedan 345 de cuota
pero decide seguir pagando los 700
si años más tarde pedro pescado va al
doble de velocidad ya bo en otros diez
mil dólares y juan pescador ha pagado
completamente su casa reflexión en los
dos han sacado la misma cantidad de
dinero de la bolsa uno es dueño de una
casa de 100 mil dólares el otro debe 70
obviamente fueron 106 mil 400 dólares en
intereses la historia no para ahí
saco un nuevo préstamo de 65 mil paga la
cuota de 700 y alquila la casa se está
abonando mil doscientos y seis años más
tarde
ha comprado su segunda casa el otro
muchacho sigue pagando hace lo mismo
ahora tiene 2 alquiladas 4 años pues ha
comprado su segunda casa el otro sigue
pagando
se compra una tercera casa a los 25 años
el otro sigue pagando el dueño del
pasaje ya con cuatro casas
el otro sigue pagando y a los 30 años
que termina de pagar
juan pescador tiene 360 mil dólares de
capital casa y 38 mil dólares de ingreso
al mes de rentas y los dos han sacado la
misma cantidad de dinero de la bolsa
la libertad financiera no tiene que ver
nada con cuánto ganas con cuánta suerte
tenés no tiene que estar absolutamente
nada con la carrera que estudiaste el 20
por ciento de conocimiento y 80 por
ciento de comportamiento
él tiene la libertad de hacer lo que lo
que su corazón lo demanda
porque los problemas financieros no
tienen que ver nada que ver con los
políticos ni con macroeconomía ni la
moneda ni desastres naturales ni
situaciones de delincuencia esas
condiciones ya las tenemos todos es en
la cancha que estamos jugando pero qué
van a hacer ustedes víctimas o
superhéroes la víctima se fije en eso el
superhéroe ve como se salta esos
obstáculos esa es la actitud que tenemos
que tener descansen cuando se mueran
ahorita están vivos delen con todo los
problemas financieros son de principios
y valores yo de verdad no me canso de
repetirlo pongamos de moda la honestidad
si la gente supiera el gran negocio que
es ser honesto nadie haría nada
equivocado
el público colorado ya se murió nadie lo
va a venir a defender el héroe de la
historia tienen que ser ustedes
tengan valor y reescriban la que dios
los bendiga
[Música]
[Aplausos]